allez viens ma puce
on n'a pas le temps une loi pour sauver
des vies à partir du 8 mars tous les
foyers français devront être équipés
d'un détecteur de fumée pierre morange
député de la 6e circonscription des
yvelines est à l'origine de ce texte
l'homme politique s'est lancé dans ce
combat suite au décès d'une jeune fille
de 16 ans dans un incendie h avenue en
2002 madame moustiques oui en fait
habiter à saint-nom-la-bretèche mais sa
fille et elle avait passé une soirée
avec des amis en effet acharné et elle
m'a replacé se raconter cette histoire
terrible larmes aux yeux avec une
dignité une émotion
qui prenait à la gorge véritablement et
pour le médecin
le maire d'un village le père de famille
le parlementaire ayant quelques lueurs
en matière de protection sanitaire et
sociale et bien évidemment je lui ai
proposé que nous nous battions ensemble
afin que de cette souffrance eh bien
nous puissions et bien la mettre au
service de tous cette histoire n'est pas
un cas isolé en moyenne 350 personnes
perdent la vie chaque année dans un
incendie domestique en france dans les
yvelines ainsi décès sont recensés par
an suite à l'inhalation de fumées
toxiques dans 70% des cas les accidents
se produisent la nuit il ya des grandes
idées qui font qu'on estime toujours que
ça va se passer chez les autres et qu'on
aura le temps de réagir au cas où et en
fait malheureusement notre expérience
montre que c'est rarement le cas et que
des drames à la fois matérielle mais
surtout humains sont des conséquences de
cette manque de préparation un détecteur
de fumée coûte en moyenne entre 15 et 25
euros un seul avertisseur peut permettre
d'assurer la sécurité d'un appartement
si votre habitation comprend plusieurs
étages il est conseillé d'installer un
détecteur à chaque palier
si on ne peut installer qu'un seul
détecteur de fumée puisque c'est le
minimum imposé par la loi il faut
privilégier le couloir qui dessert les
chambres en général puisqu'on pourra
réveillé en même temps plusieurs
personnes dans l'entente moment de la
journée où elles sont plus fragiles les
plus exposés parce qu'elle dorme dans la
cuisine ce conseil par contre c'est un
détecteur de chaleur qui lui sonnera
quand la température de la pièce sera
supérieure au fonctionnement et à la
tante normal qu'on peut avoir dans ce
genre de pièce objectif annoncé par les
soldats du feu réduire par deux le
nombre de morts dans les incendies en
france dans les prochaines années